now tell me what does the moon do ah the
moon orbits the earth I don't think it
got much let's let's do an orbit can we
do an orbit are you gonna I reckon
they're gonna stay isn't it kind of like
the same faces facing the whole time
right so kind up why don't I be doing
like you have that twisted is rough to
twist it a little bit yeah that's it
exactly Sean Sean
boo-yeah alright now I want to know why
the moon does that was it the
gravitational pull of the earth because
it's like a floating rock in space and
the earth guys come here but then
doesn't ever come there it just kind of
goes round and round around the earth
what's a gravitational force on the moon
the two graviton masses because you've
got the Earth's gravity it being the
greater object is pulling the the moon's
size into its orbit obviously put some
kind of attraction to the earth what
kind of attraction probably
gravitational I'm guessing I'm just
trying to check it you're telling me
that the moon is attracted to the earth
yes yeah I guess so yeah but it keeps
spinning around cuz it's moving at a
certain speed so it never actually
reaches the earth
it's going